on
debout
je ne sais pas
les hommes
bonsoir l'émotion ce matin une motion
des petits partagé par les grands
c'était la rentrée pour 13 millions
d'écoliers de collégiens et de lycéens
avant d'aborder les problèmes qui se
posent où pourrait se poser la qualité
de l'enseignement les conditions de vie
la formation professionnelle arrêtons
nous un instant sur la photo du jour qui
provient d'un lion on la gardera dans
l'album du 19 20 c'est mathieu le garçon
qui ferment le rang escorte ses quatre
soeurs pour ce premier jour il aura
fallu une petite heure pour préparer
tout le monde mais finalement c'est
sampler et même plutôt content que les
quintuplés ont pris ce matin pour la
première fois le chemin de l'école
la rentrée les quintuplés c'était aussi
un symbole tout trouvé pour la commune
de sourcieux qui inaugure est
aujourd'hui sa nouvelle école maternelle
et où la petite troupe a fait grimper
les effectifs pour leur première journée
les quintuplés n'ont pas bronché
pas la moindre inquiétude il est vrai
qu'à 5 on se serre les coudes mais
finalement ça ça dépendants les uns des
autres et puis ils ont chacun leur
attirance anaqua mieux les plus dense et
chaude construction le thé légaux alors
ça fait qu'ils sont ça sympa dans la
classe ça peut pas bloc on s'attendait à
une reprise de mal mais il était
tellement content si l'entrée en classe
de sarah manon mathieu margot est clair
assure tout vider la maison de leurs
parents pour eux qui viennent de fêter
leurs trois ans ce premier jour d'école
s'est passé cinq sur cinq
elles ont maintenant chez les plus
grands et voyons comment ils
appréhendent leur année scolaire
notre équipe s'est rendue dans un
collège ultramoderne de garges les
gonesse près de paris et a constaté que
la préoccupation des adolescents comme
des enseignants portaient autant sur la
vie à l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur de
l'établissement musique classique dans
le hall d'entrée équipes pédagogiques
enthousiaste et très présente le collège
de garges-lès-gonesse peut rompre veut
rompre avec l'image traditionnelle des
établissements de banlieue
le proviseur espère surtout que ses
élèves préférons les salles de classe
aux rues de la cité reportage nathalie
darrigand et christophe airaud il y a
deux ans les élèves du collège henri
wallon effectué ici dans ces
préfabriqués leur rentrée aujourd'hui
tout a changé
200 mètres plus loin un établissement
tout neuf
leur ouvre ses portes 9h ce matin il y
avait foule devant la grille ce sont les
petits de 6e qui trépignent
le principal et les enseignants sont sur
leur 31 musique classique en fond sonore
ici la rentrée décidément très étonnante
on ne peut plus comme ça tu se faire par
le passé le maître des barrier avait
rempart entre la cité le collège il faut
s'adapter faut s'adapter à notre
avantage n'est pas question d'ouvrir le
collège pour qu'il se passe n'importe
quoi mais par contre il faut qu'on
s'adapte et qu'on prenne en compte tout
ce qui se passe a cité à titre d'exemple
cet été l'établissement est resté ouvert
résultat ce matin la plupart des élèves
connaissaient déjà les lieux ouais super
bien mais on peut se faire des copains à
l'épreuve sont sympas en israël via
souvent les surveillants ici ils ne
chôment pas car si l'ambiance est bonne
il faut tout de même multiplié les
activités pour réussir à intéresser les
élèves est vrai que tout ce qui est fait
genre sorties éducatives voyage tout ça
c'est pour les intégrer à la vie du
collège
j'en donne une motivation supplémentaire
on se rend compte que dans sa marche
après on arrive à faire le travail
d'enseignant réussi renseigner réussir à
éloigner les élèves des problèmes de la
cité
le temps d'une année et si possible le
temps d'une scolarité
et précisément pour protéger davantage
des collèges et les lycées
philippe marchand a souhaité aujourd'hui
une plus grande coopération entre
enseignants et policiers le ministre de
l'intérieur a demandé aux îlotiers
d'être très présents autour des
établissements scolaires
edith cresson de son côté s'est
intéressée à l'avenir des collégiens et
à leur entrée dans le monde
professionnel
le premier ministre en visite à reims a
insisté sur la nécessité de valoriser
d'enseignement professionnel et
l'apprentissage est un premier ministre
a annoncé que les premiers à mesure
concrète serait arrêté fin septembre en
conseil des ministres et qu'il y aurait
plus de crédits pour l'apprentissage
reportage sur place à reims de
marie-hélène tichoux et de mes poupe à
un lycée modèle pour la rentrée des
classes du premier ministre un lycée
technique tout neuf qui a juste cinq ans
un lycée qui va contre les a priori
on sait pourtant comme une cité avant
que la patience et vous
flimm offrir les agapes
pour l'instant des jeunes choisissent
encore les filières classiques au
détriment des filières professionnelles
le premier ministre a réaffirmé le
besoin de mettre en adéquation formation
et emploi et a lancé un appel solennel à
tous les acteurs enseignants chefs
d'entreprises jeunes pour lutter contre
le chômage mais aussi un appel vers les
familles à savoir que les taux de
chômage des jeunes issus des filières
professionnelles et techniques
industrielles en particulier celles qui
sont représentés dans cet établissement
sont inférieurs à ceux observés à des
niveaux plus élevés dans les filières
générales c'est un fait qui est
fréquemment ignorer rapprocher les
entreprises de l'éducation nationale
décentralisée pour plus d'efficacité
pour donner plus d'autonomie aux
établissements
les décisions seront annoncées d'ici la
fin de l'année mais avant le 25
septembre un projet de loi sur
l'alternance et l'apprentissage sera
présenté en conseil des ministres
devra-t-on payer des cotisations encore
plus forte c'est possible si on lit avec
attention les prévisions de l'unedic sur
le financement de l'assurance chômage si
rien n'est fait dans les mois à venir le
déficit de l'assurance chômage pourrait
en effet atteindre 16 milliards de
francs à la fin 92 c'est bien sûr l'une
des conséquences de l'aggravation du
chômage un chiffre catastrophe révélée
ce matin par nos confrères de libération
bernard ségara au fur et à mesure que
l'anpe inscrire les nouveaux chômeurs
les assedic versent de plus en plus de
prestations au fur et à mesure que
l'emploi se dégrade les assedic
perçoivent de moins en moins de
cotisations depuis un an
l'assurance chômage a vu le nombre de
ses allocataires augmenté de 250 mille
cotisations en baisse allocations en
hausse et les comptes de l'unedic vire
au rouge
pour cette année le trou serait de 7
milliards et même de 9 milliards en 92
syndicats et patronat qui gèrent
paritairement le système vont devoir
rapidement prendre des décisions on
pense déjà à l'augmentation des
cotisations mais le patronat préconise
d'abord un grand ménage
il ya un certain nombre d'exemples qui
montrent qu'il ya peut-être un certain
laxisme dans les années
je crois qu'il faut indemniser
correctement ceux qui sont véritablement
chômeurs et qui sont à la recherche d'un
emploi et qui sont disponibles
encore une autre une fois et puis pour
les autres voir s'il relève
véritablement du régime du chômage dans
le collimateur du cnpf déjà les
professions du spectacle qu'ils
percevraient cinq fois plus qu'elle ne
verse aux assedic
mais au delà ce que vise aussi bien le
cnpf que le ministère du travail
c'est un grand nettoyage dans les rangs
des chômeurs avec un renforcement des
contrôles qui se solderait par des
radiations en masse des fichiers le chef
de l'état abordera sans aucun doute
cette actualité sociale demain à 16
heures au cours d'une conférence de
presse qui sera solennelle qui sera
donné à l'elysée et qui fera l'objet
d'une édition spéciale du 19/20 arlette
chabot vous la suivez attentivement bien
sûr pourquoi françois mitterrand et
profile à nouveau le besoin de parler
mais tout simplement parce que ses
précédentes interventions télévisées ont
été ratées ou en tout cas où manquaient
leur but aujourd'hui en tout cas le
président est en difficulté
l'arrivée des discrétions avec lui mais
on n'a pas créé ce fameux ayant qu'elle
devait impulser et qu'elle devait aussi
incarné et puis surtout pour la première
fois le président de la république est
contestée sur ce domaine cette chasse
gardée qu'est la politique étrangère
après sa réaction ou tentative de putsch
en union soviétique qui l a déclenché
une offensive extrêmement forte de
l'opposition et cela c'est donc pour la
première fois alors demain et bien ce
sera la contre-offensive du chef de
l'état à tous les niveaux d'abord en
politique étrangère évidemment sur le
plan européen le président de la
république devrait insister à la fois
sur la nécessité de consolider l'europe
des 12 et puis sera-t-il un geste sans
doute en direction de l'est par exemple
en relançant son idée de confédérations
qui avaient été mal accueillie il y a
quelques semaines il devrait sans doute
la développer et puis recadrage sur le
plan intérieur le chômage la politique
économique les fameuses privatisations
dont on parle beaucoup et puis recadrage
aussi sur le plan politique françois
mitterrand était le candidat d'union de
la gauche
que reste-t-il aujourd'hui de l'union de
la gauche après les événements en union
soviétique le pc est moribond et le
parti socialiste préfère s appeler
aujourd'hui social démocrate il pourrait
donc dessiner les contours d'une future
majorité relève le bit contre-offensive
prendre at il dit
spectaculaire alors il ya des rumeurs
qui circulent depuis hier départ d'eddie
cresson c'est peu probable présidente
peut se désavouer quelques semaines
après avoir nommé madame cresson qu'au
contraire doit être conforté et puis
rumeurs sur un référendum sur la
réduction du mandat présidentiel on
pense à 1984 là aussi le président était
en difficulté il avait lancé l'idée d'un
référendum sur le référendum pour mettre
cours aux attaques de l'opposition
là c'est vrai que tout le monde est
d'accord sur l'idée de réduire le mandat
présidentiel dont il y aura une majorité
pour le faire
cela dit il peut y avoir un effet
boomerang le président pourrait être
obligée dire l opposition de sa fille qu
à lui-même ses traductions je pense
surtout demain que le président voudra
montrer aux français qui égare
d'initiative qu'il est en mouvement
face à ceux qui pensent qu'il est usé
par le pouvoir cette éventualité d'une
réduction du mandat présidentiel revient
systématiquement depuis de longues
années mais on a fini par ne plus y
croire tant elle ressemble à
l'arlésienne
michel lemaire la logique du septennat
date d'une époque où le président de la
république avait des pouvoirs assez
symbolique s'appliquant un président aux
prérogatives étendues
cette durée a été critiqué dès l'origine
de la vème république françois
mitterrand s'est prononcé depuis plus de
vingt ans pour le quinquennat il n'a pas
varié sur ce point réduire le mandat
présidentiel me paraît tout à fait
raisonnable en soit la réforme même déjà
été votées en 73 sous georges pompidou
par les deux assemblées
mais la procédure n'avait pas été menée
jusqu'à son terme le principe du
quinquennat recueille l'adhésion de la
grande majorité des formations
politiques à l'exception des barriste du
parti communiste et d'une poignée de
gaullistes historiques
il y a moins de dix jours giscard le
réclamait avec force à la tribune des
universités de cabourg
une telle réforme poserait néanmoins
plusieurs problèmes
le président de la république
s'appliquera-t-il cette nouvelle
disposition rien ne l'y oblige
il a été élu sur la base de la règle
actuelle il livrait un indice le 14
juillet j'accomplirai mon mandat jusqu'à
son terme constituer chaleur et puis il
faudrait t'il ou non faire coïncider
l'élection présidentielle et celle de
l'assemblée ne pas le faire aggraverait
les risques de cohabitation périlleuse
la jonction en revanche des deux
scrutins bouleverserait l'actuel
équilibre constitutionnel
l'entêtement des républiques baltes
récompenser les trois nouveaux états
sont entrés aujourd'hui dans le club
européen jusqu'à présent réticents
depuis ce matin les membres de la csc la
conférence sur la sécurité et la
coopération en europe ne sont plus en
effet 35 mais 38 enrichit les
représentants des trois pays bat la csc
a mis cette réunion extraordinaire sous
le signe des droits de l'homme hélène
francs dont moscou capitale des droits
de l'homme moscou choisi il y a deux ans
après de longues discussions pour
accueillir les ministres des affaires
étrangères européens et nord-américains
moscou surtout impatiente de prouver que
les temps ont changé que la démocratie
est en marche comme l'a expliqué michael
gorbatchev très applaudi ce matin à
l'ouverture de la conférence
en dépit de nombreuses critiques
commente le chef du kremlin la
pérestroïka a fait beaucoup au cours des
six dernières années
notre principale tâche est d'accélérer
les réformes démocratiques
vers une économie de marché témoin de
ces changements
l'entrée des pays baltes dans la csc eux
en novembre dernier au sommet de paris
l'urss avait refusé qui les assistent
aux travaux sous prétexte qu'il aurait
fallu reconnaître l'indépendance baltes
aujourd'hui c'est l'union soviétique
elle même acquis annoncé leur adhésion à
la conférence mais en échange de sa
bonne volonté
l'union compte bien demander une aide
financière accrue
du côté des européens et des états unis
cette conférence est aussi l'occasion de
connaître mieux la nouvelle direction
soviétique et surtout de tester ses
relations avec les républiques et les
minorités nationales
et justement ces petits pas vers la
démocratie ainsi que l'occident à
soutenir plus activement et
financièrement l'union soviétique ou
plus précisément les républiques de plus
en plus autonome des rencontres se
multiplient 15 heures à peine après leur
déclaration d'indépendance les nouveaux
ministres craignent un prennent en effet
leur bâton de pèlerin
ils sont en europe pour convaincre les
investisseurs de venir s'implanter chez
eux
mais si le discours est volontariste et
dynamique les chefs d'entreprises
français restent sceptiques
on a la nette impression d'assister un
dialogue de sourds la rencontre s'est
passé au centre français du commerce
extérieur martin thibault et marque doux
comment assurer la continuité des
affaires qui sont les nouveaux décideurs
qui va désormais garantir les crédits
autant de questions très concrètes
à parterre d'industriels français apposé
à trois représentants du gouvernement
ukrainien le directeur de la banque
centrale valentin terreau pilot le
ministre de la privatisation michel
bailly jaca enfin valentin palchine
conseiller scientifique un gouvernement
ukrainien a désorganisé depuis la
proclamation de l'indépendance il y a
quinze jours à peine
mais dont le premier geste est de tendre
la main aux occidentaux
vos experts dont nous apprendra
reconstruit notre pays notre économie
notre métallurgie notre industrie lourde
à quels projets communs devons-nous
participer pour accélérer ensemble notre
reconstruction
aidez nous à reconstruire un appel que
nos industriels reçoivent avec beaucoup
de prudence qui est important pour nous
c'est d'une part de connaître où se
trouvent les pouvoirs de décision les
circuits de décision
c'est très important est également où se
trouvent les pouvoirs qu'ils peuvent
comme on dit refinancer les grandes
opérations industrielles possible dans
ce pays ceci dans l'avenir il y avait un
thé je vais refaire un disque et rapport
justement nous serions intéressés
le pôle instant il est vraiment trop tôt
pour en parler pour l'instant que le
disais nous sommes dans rapport avec les
eysines et si nous pensons qu'il est
dans l'intérêt de leurs notes de travail
ensemble nous le fort pour convaincre
des industriels il faudra plus que des
promesses
il faudra la caution et la mobilisation
de l'aide internationale qui sont
maintenant dans les mains des
gouvernements occidentaux d ordre
politique à l'est d ordre social à
l'ouest des affrontements d'une grande
violence ont opposé la nuit dernière des
centaines de jeunes à des policiers dans
la cité de norshield en angleterre
les émeutes se poursuivent en fait
depuis plusieurs jours et parfois et
policiers n'osent plus intervenir de
peur d'envenimer encore la situation
morad aït habbouche dans la cité 2002
well près de newcastle le calme est
revenu ce matin
pourtant dans ce quartier populaire la
nuit a été chaude pendant cinq heures
les jeunes des cités se sont révoltés
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
les dégâts sont importants immeubles
incendiés magasins pillés quatre jeunes
ont été arrêtés à l'origine de cette
explosion de violence la mort de deux
adolescents le week-end dernier
poursuivi par la police dell et collines
deux jeunes de 17 et 21 ans au volant
d'une voiture volée se sont écrasés
contre un lampadaire course-poursuite et
rodéos nocturnes qui ont déjà provoqué
ailleurs en grande-bretagne des émeutes
comme ici à oxford il ya une semaine ces
scènes ont également eu lieu à
birmingham et à cardiff au pays de
galles
après la france et la belgique le
royaume-uni découvre le malaise des
banlieues en france est désormais une
certitude des hémophiles sont devenus
séropositifs à la suite d'erreurs
commises par le centre de transfusion
sanguine et les autorités médicales
il faut être bien clair le rapport rendu
au ministère de la santé ce matin est
une chronologie des événements entre 80
et 85 mais en aucun cas un dossier
d'accusation
hiller il relève aussi tu es certain
retard dans les prises de décision mais
n'accable pas le centre national de
transfusion sanguine
clément weill-raynal la contamination
des hémophiles par le virus du sida
aurait-elle pu être évitée
le rapport de l'igas ne répond pas de
manière catégorique
mais une chose est sûre la prise de
conscience de la menace a pris un
certain temps souligne le rapport
laps de temps forcément trop long c'est
ce que sous-entend l'igas c'est en mai
85 que l'on réalise que les produits
sanguins sont porteurs du virus
or leur retrait du marché n'interviendra
qu'en octobre pendant quatre mois
des centaines d'hémophiles vont être
contaminés y at il eu négligence
mensonge ou dissimulation
rien ne permet de l'affirmer à la
lecture du rapport qui précise bien qu
en 1985 la signification de la
séropositivité n'est pas encore
totalement perçu à l'époque on pense
encore à tort que l'immense majorité des
séropositifs ne développera pas la
maladie pour ce qui est de la technique
du chauffage qui aurait pu éviter la
contamination
le rapport souligne qu'à l'époque on ne
maîtrisait cette technique que dans un
tube à essai la décision
ministériel de retirer les produits non
chauffés prise le 23 juillet ne prendra
effet qu'en octobre à l'époque médecins
et autorités de tutelle estime que cette
période transitoire est vitale pour les
hémophiles
on veut éviter avant tout la rupture de
stock il y a bien eu erreur
d'appréciation souligne le rapport
mais cette erreur a été collective
samuel costa résume les autres
événements qui se sont produits en
france
sept personnes dont cinq mineurs de 15
ans devant la cour d'assises de haute
savoie ils sont poursuivis pour une
série d'agressions contre des personnes
âgées quatre assassinats plusieurs
tentatives d'assassinât vol aggravé avec
violence en 88 il avait sévi dans la
région pendant neuf mois
le procès se déroule à huis clos
les obsèques de mokrane gouttes meurt le
fils de harki retrouverait étranglé le 5
août dans la cité des oliviers à
narbonne se sont déroulées ce matin dans
le calme deux cent cinquante personnes
ont accompagné le corps au cimetière
les expertises n'ont toujours pas permis
d'établir avec certitude s'il s'agit
d'un suicide ou d'un assassinat
dorénavant l'instruction des jeunes
appelés se fera dans leur unité
d'affectation où ils resteront jusqu'à
la fin de leur période de service
national l'instruction sera prolongée le
ministre pierre joxe espère ainsi
obtenir une amélioration de la situation
d appeler les pièces 10 francs en cuivre
mise en circulation en 74 retirer d'ici
fin octobre
trop grande trop lourde facilement
imitable et souvent indigeste pour les
distributeurs
en attendant les usagers pourront les
échanger contre les nouvelles pièces
bicolore dans les banques à la poste et
dans les bureaux du trésor public
les champions mike tyson fait toujours
parler de lui-même lorsqu'il ne monte
pas sur un ring
une jeune fille l'accuse de l'avoir
courtisé à sa manière violemment laissé
en liberté contre une caution de 30
mille dollars le boxeur risque 63 ans de
prison s'il est reconnu coupable
mais il a toujours nié les faits les
prochains championnats du monde pourrait
tout de même être remise en question
jean philippe guignet véritable taureau
des rings l'ancien champion du monde des
poids lourds n'a jamais fait dans la
dentelle lorsqu'il tentait d'obtenir les
faveurs d'une femme c'est maintenant une
jeune participante au concours de miss
black america qui l'accuse de l'avoir
violée à indianapolis en juillet dernier
le boxeur nie les faits d'autant que la
scène se serait déroulée dans sa propre
chambre d'hôtel selon la plaignante
tyson a convaincu de la compagnie avant
d'abuser d'elle mike tyson est également
inculpé de séquestration et de conduite
criminelle
l'enquète a duré quatre semaines et 28
témoins ont déjà été entendus
le procureur général indianapolis a
précisé que s'il y avait procès il ne se
déroulerait pas avant la fin de l'année
la caution serait déjà glissé à 30000
dollars
tyson est maintenant un habitué des
tribunaux déjà plusieurs fois accusée
par des femmes pour harcèlement sexuel
il a également dû divorcer du top model
robin given la vedette d'origine harlem
actuellement sur les écrans
l'accusé d'être très violent est
maniaco-dépressif pour l'instant tyson
garde le sourire et préfère se
concentrer sur la préparation de son
prochain combat pour le titre de
champion du monde contre evander
holyfield
mi novembre prochain mais d'ores et déjà
l'université de wilberforce en ohio peut
se poser des questions en avril 89 tyson
s'était vu remettre un superbe diplôme
pour son rôle et son influence positive
sur la jeunesse dans son pays
aujourd'hui ils risquent 63 ans de
prison et pour terminer le 19 ans reste
fidèle à sa vocation vous faire
découvrir les jeunes talents des années
90 aujourd'hui patrick kane si le nom
est difficile à prononcer mais la jeune
fille est agréable à regarder et à
écouter
twenty one 21 c'est le titre du film mes
21 ans c'est aussi l'âge de la majorité
en grande-bretagne l'héroïne du film on
a en fait 23 vous allez déjà un sérieux
palmarès à son actif michel vial et
patrick mille herriot l'ont rencontré
révélée par absolute beginners et parle
arme fatale numéro 2 langlès patsy
kensit est devenu en quelques mois la
nouvelle coqueluche d'hollywood et le
festival de deauville est également
tombé sous son charme pétillant à
travers le film twenty one de john boyd
où elle incarne une jeune femme riche en
aventures érotiques mais à qui ne manque
encore que le grand amour
je pense qu'elle est un personnage
drôlement compliqué mais qu'elle est
vraiment nature et très extraverti pour
tout ce qui concerne le sexe elle se
comporte comme un homme sûr et solide
pourtant elle est à la fois un côté
vénérable et naïf qu'elle n'admettra
jamais d'ailleurs chaque niche il n'a
pas deux mètres sur trois niveaux
empathique et si tu sembles cohabiter
joie de vivre et d enchantement en tout
cas elle fait preuve d'une vraie
distance sur sa notoriété
il est vrai qu'elle n'est plus une
débutante d'où sa méfiance pour la mode
je pense qu'il est très dangereux dans
cette profession de devenir célèbre ou
bien plus connu pour son image que pour
son travail et bien sûr quand on joue
les gens s'intéressent davantage à votre
vie privée
certains artistes adorent la célébrité
c'est une chose qui m'intéressait au
début de ma carrière mais qui ne
m'intéresse plus du tout je suis très
désireuse de préserver ma vie privée
tranquille
merci le bois demain matin vous le début
du mois écoulé on n'ira pas plus loin
marc hautement 22h10 pour d'autres infos
et la météo qu'on fait de michèle torr
et dans quelques secondes bon soir et
demain 19h bonsoir